celebrities and politicians flaunting
their fortunes and political messages at
the swanky met gala in new york city
hillary clinton getting called out for
the optics of going mask-less as a mass
staffer attends to her gown new york
city mayor eric adams sporting an end
gun violence tuxedo as crime soars in
his city and kim kardashian stunning
people everywhere with her sparkling
five million dollar dress that marilyn
monroe award to sing happy birthday to
president john f kennedy
greg would you like to talk about kim
kardashian's dress no i couldn't believe
that did you see what killed me wore
unbelievable he showed so much skin it
was disgusting been working out it's
weird though it does show how
people who like to define themselves as
edgy rebellious or artistic or whatever
and they love to stand out but they're
they just have such a desperate need to
belong
that when one of these events happens
they flock to it and they all get
dressed up and they all obey and they
conform to the collective need to be
seen it's like you don't need to go to
these things but it's like this is
replacing the oscars and and somebody
tells them their publicist says you have
to be seen but hillary in the dress with
the with the the african-american or the
black gentleman in the mask you know
holding her skirt or her train i mean
that's the hierarchy that's the
structure that makes the elites happy
you follow the rules
you follow the rules they don't have to
you're down there i'm up here
joey do you think that the average
person who might have caught a glimpse
of this and obviously last night this
was not the big news story with the
abortion case leak but do you think
that's how they feel about this or they
just think this is what rich people do
and
i think the average person doesn't know
what in the hell the met gala is or care
listen if you've got enough hubris and
money to go dress like a star wars
character and be looked at yeah go do it
i don't i don't have any i don't condemn
any of this what i condemn is those same
people walking a block over the next day
and holding some press release about how
we gotta you know tax the rich like you
you know pick your side you know be a
little bit consistent a little bit less
of a hypocrite and we'll get along just
fine i i don't know any i know some of
those people but not really well and i
really don't care they had a good time i
really don't care that they dressed up
more like idiots for a night and called
it fashion i don't care about that at
all what i care about is them telling me
what i do with my money or even worse
telling elon musk what he should do with
his money that's that's the hypocrisy of
it all and uh i guess we just expect
democrats to do democrat things i guess
i don't know
well you don't know if that was your
final word uh dana
i think one of the worst things that
could ever happen to me would be to be
invited to that thing
like i
would i would cringe the entire time i'd
make greg go with me yes so that we
could at least make sure yes we could do
a costume pair
like i don't know oh yeah tweet us tell
us what we could be oh boy
uh the white house correspondents dinner
it's just like it's perfect it's just so
far and i'm sure that everybody there
really truly believed that rich people
should have their student loans paid off
i'm sure that was a high topic of
conversation i would go as mr met
the big giant guy
with a big head
i'll go we're not going to afford
nickel-plated legs
um you know i i don't begrudge them
doing this i what i do begrudge is you
know sometimes i think the mayor
probably spent more time on ending gun
violence uh in terms of making that suit
and putting it on than he has and
actually trying to end gun violence
because when he went to albany came back
he yelled at the press because he didn't
like you know he didn't want to answer
how he failed in albany i love that elon
musk brought his mother now i love him
even more and uh you know but you know
let him do their thing they're happy
with themselves
you know good for them who cares i
didn't know his mom used to be a
supermodel yes she was a superhero it
was mom did you just yes
she was on the cover of many many
fashion magazines you can look it up yes
i will look it up and yeah i'm excited
yes hey sean hannity here hey click here
to subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere else